nommé le Père la Victoire euh donc voilà
qui finalement qui fait c'est lui qui
mène la France à la victoire à la fin de
la première guerre mondiale voilà et ce
que je voulais rajouter peut-être aussi
c'est que la flamme que vous voyez
évidemment là qui est sous l'Arc de
Triomphe et donc là symboliquement c'est
le soldat
inconnu qui symbolise tous les les les
les soldats morts et et disparus dont on
n pas retrouvé les corps de la guerre du
14 cette flamme là euh évidemment elle
est ravivée tous les jours à heure fixe
18h je crois cette Flam elle sert à
raviver aussi et c'est la continuité
entre les deux guerres puisqu'on dit
aussi que c'est une guerre de 30 ans
souvent la première et la seconde et
qu'en fait cette flamme là elle sert à
aller raviver la flamme qui est au
Mémorial du montvalérien voilà donc
c'est le lien entre les deux il y a des
de guerr entre les deux guerres et puis
il y a des combattants il y a des
combattants qui ont fait les deux
guerres je je j'ai j'ai un grand tle qui
était combattant des deux guerres qui a
fait 14 18 et et 39 40
voilà alors on va suivre en direct ces
images euh bien sûr qui sont fournis par
par l'Agence France Presse euh le
président Macron est attendu mais il y a
également une invitée euh particulière
aussi cette année donc la
vice-présidente des États-Unis Kamala
Haris qui est en tourné en France depuis
avant-hier pour le forum de la paix
notamment qui se déroule cet après-midi
et donc elle est conviée à l'arc de
triomphe à se recueillir donc devant la
tombe du soldat inconnu euh nous la
verrons arriver je pense que pour
l'instant ils sont justement un peu plus
bas euh dans les Champs-Élysées au
niveau donc de la statue de de Georges
clémenau on verra bien évidemment euh le
cercueil de de hbert Germain arrivé sur
un sur un char est-ce qu'on sait sur
quel char il oui al c'est un véhicule
blindé effectivement qui a été aménagé
pour ça mais c'est pas n'importe lequel
parce que vous savez que souvent dans
l'armée française on baptise les
véhicules euh de nom de bataille de
victoire et ce véhicule il porte le nom
de birakem évidemment c'est hautement
symbolique puisque Hubert Germain s'est
illustré en tant que lieutenant à la TR
bdblle lors de la bataille de birakem
donc c'est logique que ce soit un
véhicule qui porte ce noml qui l'emmène
effectivement de du dô des invalide au
bas des Champs-Élysées où il va marquer
un arrêt devant la la statue du général
de Gaulle et après remonter alors je ne
sais pas exactement après comment sera
positionné la dépouille là j'ai pas
d'information là-dessus mais voilà je
vouais peut-être ajouter une chose aussi
c'est que sur les Compagnons de la
Libération c'est intéressant de dire ça
je sais pas si Camelais le sait ou pas
mais il y a des parmi les 1038
compagnons hommes et femmes qui ont été
décorés par le général de gale vous avez
76 étrangers et dans ces étrangers vous
avez d'illustres étrangers et notamment
le général eenower le généralenower a
été fait Compagnon de la Libération par
le général de Gaulle qui est un ancien
président de la République par la suite
après la GU après la après la la fin de
de la guerre ou pendant pendant la
guerre alors on va apporter une
précision les Compagnons de la
Libération donc ils sont 1038 il y a 18
unités combattantes don la 13e d ble et
cinq villes
euh l'ordre a été ce qu'on dit for clos
fermé c'està-dire que on n plus décerné
de médaille après janvier 1946 donc
volontairement il a été limité il y a eu
deux exceptions c'est pour le roi
d'Angleterre et pour Winston Churchill
évidemment on peut le comprendre puis ce
sont eux qui ont accueilli au tout début
de la France Libre le général de Gaulle
voilà mais donc il est il a été al j'ai
pas la date mais le général Z a été
déclaré a été fait Compagnon dernière
partie de la guerre j'imagine 44 ou 45
si vous nous rejoignez merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur le Fig
Figaro.fr et sur notre page Youtube
Figaro live nous allons donc suivre en
direct et commenter c'est ces
célébrations ces commémorations plutôt
de l'armistice du 11 novembre 1918 vous
voyez donc c'est ces champs éélysées vid
bouclé d'où doivent arriver donc
normalement le président Macron mais
aussi la dépouille Dubert Germain sur un
char le dernier compagnon de la
Libération qui s'est éteint il y a un
mois et dont on rend un hommage encore
aujourd'hui après un premier hommage aux
Invalides il y a début octobre je crois
que c'était non ou oui il y a une
cérémonie tout à fait j'éis pour la
commenter tout à fait nous étions
ensemble pour la commenter en direct
également sur Figaro live alors
j'aimerais bien qu'on revienne un petit
peu sur sur Hubert
Germain qui était-il à quel âge enfin
quel âge avait-il quand il a été fait h
enfin compagnon de la Libération alors
en fait son engagement il faut fa
remonter à son engagement en fait il est
il est d'abord il est issu d'une famille
d'officiers généraux son père était
général et en 1940 en fait il est
étudiant il prépare le concours de
l'École navale et au moment de la
défaite bah il va à l'examen et en fait
il rend copie blanche et il dit ben moi
je continue je veux pas m'arrêter là je
veux pas faire ça et en fait il il s'en
va et il prend un bateau et il rejoint
l'Angleterre donc il a 19 ans voilà
comme il se desstinit plutôt à la marine
il est d'abord effectivement intégré
dans une unité
de la marine enfin des des forces
navales françaises libre et puis très
vite en fait il est basculé et il part
en Syrie et d'ailleurs il déclare à ce
moment-là ça fera plaisir au
légionnaires qui nous écoute en fait il
souhaite intégrer la Légion parce qu'il
dit je je souhaite faire la guerre avec
des vrais professionnels et donc il
intègre je crois que c'est début 42 il
intègre la 13e des ble et il se retrouve
à birakem et il fera après tous les
combats de la libération de la 13 donc
il combattra en dans le désert de Libye
à birakem à la lamen il fera la campagne
de Tunisie la campagne d'Italie durant
laquelle il est blessé puis la campagne
de France puisqu'il participe au
débarquement de Provence le 15 16 août
44 et après il fait il fait toute la
remontée en France avec la 13e des ble
participe à des combats très durs
notamment en Alsace lors des combats du
du Ballon d'Alsace et les derniers
combats de la Libération il combat
jusqu'en fin 45 et et il se trouve il
devient adjoint ou Chef Chef
d'État-major ou ou a de camp pardon du
général Kenig qu'il avait connu
évidemment pendant la guerre du désert
et après il quitte
l'armée pour entamer une carrière dans
le privé puis après politique parce
qu'il deviendra élu député maire de la
ville de Saint-Chéron en région
parisienne deux fois ministre euh
ministre des PTT c'est ça alors ministre
des PTT et ministre des Relations avec
le Parlement aussi je dis pas de bêtises
et on apprend donc dans dans votre petit
quiz on a une citation donc d'Hubert
Germain au moment où il est parti en
Angleterre justement en le 24 juin
1940 je je je cite donc Hubert Germain
c'était un moment émouvant quand vous
voyez disparaître les côtes françaises
et que à ce moment-là vous avez réussi
une partie du parcours et vous vous
dites reverrai-je un jour la France et
quand il débarque en août le 15 ou 16
août 44 en Provence euh le les premiers
moments où il arrive je crois que c'est
le premier soir et en fait il il pleure
en fait parce que il avait pas vu la
France évidemment depuis 4 ans euh il a
un gros moment d'émotion à ce moment-là
parce que en plus c'est un moment où
très peu de temps après il retrouve une
partie de sa famille je crois que son
père été si je dis pas de bêtis son père
a été arrêté déporté voilà donc le
retour sur la terre de France pour lui a
été évidemment chargé d'émotion comme il
a été quand il est parti parce qu'il
savait pas où il allait en fait à 19 ans
voilà faut savoir que les Compagnons de
la Libération et c'est un des critères
c'est c'est ils sont d'abord une grande
ils sont effectivement très jeunes leur
engagement 75 76 % sont des des gens qui
s'engagent euh avant fin 40 et plus de
90 % je crois que c'est 91 ou 93 %
s'engagent avant fin 42 voilà donc oui
ils sont très jeunes parce que
évidemment quand vous avez charge de
famille c'est plus c'est moins évident
il y a beaucoup de de jeunes Daniel
Cordier qui était l'avant-dernier des
compagnons s'engage au même âge
d'ailleurs il était à Bordeaux tout
comme tout comme l'était Hubert Germain
puisqu'il suit ses études prépa pour
naval voilà oui c'est c'est beaucoup de
jeunes bien sûr bien sûr et puis c'est
pas mal de militaires euh bon voilà
parce que évidemment ça se comprend
bonjour Michel Lucas bonjour Martin
strugas de nous rejoindre merci de nous
rejoindre sur sur YouTube sur notre chat
Figaro live merci d'être avec nous nous
sommes en direct donc jusqu'à midi
environ pour pour suivre les
commémorations du du 11 novembre et je
vais saluer Christian Léon toussin sur
le chat du figaro.fr et Charles Martel
Christian léontoussin qui est évidemment
un habitué de Figaro live qui nous
souhaite qui nous dit bonjour et qui
nous pose une question est-ce que le
cercueil va être honoré sur un engin
blindé de reconnaissance oui c'est
exactement ça on en a parlé tout à
l'heure et qui porte le nom on va on va
le redire qui porte le nom de la
bataille de pakem symboliquement puisque
Hubert Germain a combattu et c'est
illustré euh lors de la bataille de
birakem alors on a appris juste avant
par par vous Grégoire tona qui qui
s'était engagé enfin qu'il était parti
en Angleterre on va dire en 1940 le 21
juin pour être précis est-ce que c'est
l'appel du 18 juin qui a été décisif
pour lui ou c'est une bonne question
euh beaucoup des T premiers euh qui
s'engagent et qui rejoignent le général
de gale n'ont pas entendu le discours
très peu de gens en fait ont entendu
l'appel du 10 juin en revanche ils
réagissent et ils en réaction au
discours du maréchal Pétin et cordiel
racontait très bien dans son livre alias
Caracala que quand il entend le discours
du maréchal Pétin en disant que la
guerre était finie qu'il fallait
demander il fallait négocier avec les
Allemands ils montent dans sa chambre et
ils font en larm mais c'est pas possible
moi je suis patriote je n'admets pas ça
je je ne peux pas concevoir une telle
chose et et et ça c'est ce qui préside à
sa décision tout comme l'a fait uber
Germain aussi mais on peut pas je c'est
impossible ce qui un élément une des
valeur clé des compagnons c'est le refus
de l'adversité c'estàdire que même si
tout est perdu parce que ils ont
évidemment entre eux et ça c'est le
fruit de leur éducation leur culture ils
sont patriotes et en fait eux ils
n'admettent pas la défaite et donc quoi
qu'il arrive il continuent et il
continuent à combattre et ils veulent
aller combattre les Allemands alors pour
pour pour rappeler à nos internautes à
ceux qui nous suivre de ce discours de
céit le discours du maréchal Pétin c'est
ça 1 juste avant qui qui qui déclar
l'armistice en fait qui demande l'arrêt
des hostilités et qui annonce qu'il va
négocier avec les Allemands voilà et
donc ça a eu lieu juste avant l'appel du
général de le 17 juin voilà et le
l'appel du 18 juin c'est le 18 juin bien
sûr voilà alors vous avez évoqué un
petit peu donc ce qui pousse on va dire
ces jeunes à à s'engager on va dire dans
dans dans la libération de la France
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres valeurs euh
alors il y a un critère oua il y a un
élément qui est important c'est que la
plus de la moitié des alors si on parle
des Compagnons de la Libération qui ne
sont pas tous les résistants mais qui
sont un ordre un peu chevalier c'est les
premiers des premiers euh près de la
moitié un peu plus de la moitié des
compagnons qui s'engagent ce sont des
gens qui ont qui ont bénéficié d'une
éducation un peu supérieure par rapport
à la moyenne de l'époque c'est-à-dire
que 50 % on le B à l'époque ou avant
guerre l'ensemble de la population qui a
le bac c'est à peu près 10% voilà donc
c'est vrai que
l'éducation ouais l'éducation en
forcément mais l'éducation effectivement
permet aussi bah voilà c'est un un
élément qui explique cet engagement
merci Grégoire on va continuer de de
suivre en direct ces images donc il est
il est 11h normalement donc le le
président Emmanuel Macron doit doit
arriver sous l'Arc de de Triomphe il y a
déjà beaucoup d'officiels qui sont là
beaucoup de de généraux de de
l'armée sont difficilee offici supérieur
je crois avec le ruban rouge je crois
que c'est le général Puga qui est le
patron entre guillemets de l'ordre de la
Légion d'Honneur voilà donc en France
vous savez que si vous avez un certain
nombre d'ordre de décoration l'ordre le
premier ordre c'est la Légion d'honneur
et qui lui n'est pas limité dans le
temps puisque elle été créée par
Napoléon et on décerne évidemment encore
des légions d'honneur et le second ordre
en terme de hiérarchie de protocole
c'est l'ordre de la Libération c'est la
Croix de la Libération voilà et Hubert
Germain all avait les deux distinctions
oui oui et et plus que ça il y avait
d'autres d'autres d'autres décorations
oui je crois que c'est le général Puga
qu'on voit j'ai entrevu tout à l'heure
aussi le général de
saint-chama pour parler de lui 2 minutes
le général de saint-chama qui a commandé
d'ailleurs la Légion étrangère il y a
quelques années est aujourd'hui le
général qui commande l'Institut des
Invalides où était où a vécu le jeun
enfin Hubert Germain pour ces dernières
années et c'est lui on l'a vu souvent
sur sur des images la télévision donc
c'est lui qui avait la charge et ses
équipes évidemment parce que c'est un
hôpital faut rappeler que les invalides
sont toujours un hôpital militaire et
c'est une maison de retraite c'est une
maison de retraite un hôpital et une
maison de retraite et donc Hubert
Germain a vécu les derniers moments euh
à l'hôtel des Invalides
voilà alors lors de lors de l'hommage
qu'on avait suivi ensemble aux invalide
le cercueil du berggermain était était
porté par par des hommes de la 13 de la
13e
j'imagine qu'aujourd'hui ils sont aussi
bien représentés prés présents ils vont
être présents oui euh alors hier pendant
le lorsque son sa dépouille a été
exposée au sous le dô des Invalides en
fait il y avait plus que des hommes de
la 1 il y avait des des soldats des des
18 unités combattantes qui ont été
faites Compagnons de la Libération donc
vous avvez des des aviateurs des marins
et l'armée de terre et qui se relayait
au fil de la
journée comme garde autour du du de la
de la dépouille du cercueil du
bergermain vous les avez rencontré vous
les hommes de la tresse pour écrire
votre petit quiz oui j'ai eu la chance
d'être en immersion quelques jours sur
le plateau du Larzac qui est une
expérience à la fois riche euh euh
physique même si j'ai pas fait vous avez
fait les entraînements non non non non
non mais c'est c'est un camp qui grand
et voilà et puis immense respect pour la
légion pour les hommes de la 13 parce
que parce que parce que voilà c'est des
hommes qui sont toujours aux
avant-postes la 13 c'est une unité qui a
perdu dans son histoire la 13 on peut
peut-être parler de la 13 la 13e dblle
donc 13e demi-brigade de Légion
étrangère elle est créée en février 40
au moment où on va constituer le corps
expéditionnaire qui va aller combattre
en Norvège d'accord donc eux partent en
avril et combattent en Norvège entre
avril et juin 40 jusqu'au au début de la
dé bacle euh et on dit d'ailleurs de la
1 qu'elle a participé aux deux seules
vraies victoires de cette période-là
mais juin 40 euh puisque ce ce sont eux
qui participent à la prise il y a des
des unités il y a des troupes alpines
aussi mais qui participent à la prise de
Narvic ça c'est un nom qui peut-être
raisonne encore dans les dans les
mémoires des gens euh voilà et puis la
13 elle est après rapatrié d'abord en
France et peu de temps dans la région
bretonne et puis après euh au moment où
vraiment la les combats s'arrêtent euh
il se retrouve en Angleterre et c'est à
ce moment-là que le chef de corps qui
commande la 13e DBLE général à l'époque
il est pas général mais lieutenant
colonel Magrin versnet son nom de guerre
c'est Ralph montclard et c'est lui qui
va rallier la France libre et donc les 2
tiers de ce de ce régiment de cette
unité vont rallier la France libre c'est
la première unité constituée à se
rallier au général de GA et ça c'est
important et c'est dès ce moment-là
qu'ubert Germain en fait partie ou non
Hubert Germain rejoint la 13 donc sur
aliment pour le situer c'est tout à fait
en juin 40 je sais plus si c'est le 29
28 29 ou 30 juin donc c'est vraiment au
tout début luubert Germain
lui vient d'arriver puisque vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure il embarque le 21 je
sais pas à quelle date il arrive enfin
voilà et après il se retrouve dans une
unité enfin au sein de la Marine et puis
progressivement et il va aller il va se
retrouver en Syrie et il va intégrer
l'armée de terre et il va rejoindre je
crois que c'est début 42 la 13e des ble
et pour se retrouver à birakem pour
revenir à la 13 donc la 13 elle
participer à tous les principaux combats
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale donc elle
sera effectivement en Tunisie en Italie
elle fera la campagne de Provence bah ce
qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure en parlant
du du parcours de du bergemin puisqu'il
est officier de la 13 voilà et puis
après elle va continuer puisque dès 46
elle part en Indochine et elle combat et
d'ailleurs ça sera la dernière unité à
quitter le territoire de l'indochchine
en 55 pour après embrayer immédiatement
après sur la guerre d'Algérie donc en
fait on dit d'ailleurs au sein de la 13
on dit que à 21 jours de formation
puisque l'unité venait d'être constituée
en février 40 qu' ces 21 jours de
formation donc c'estàd pas grand-chose
vont suivre 21 années de combat jusqu'à
la la fin de la guerre d'Algérie euh
voilà et donc ils perdront c'est c'est
c'est un myth ou c'est c'est une légende
ou c'est ah non non non c'est réel c'est
réel puisqueen fait ils sont engagés de
40 alors 21 ans 61 62 la fin de la
guerre d'Algérie euh non non non c'est
tout à fait voilà et c'est une unité qui
a qui a payé le lourdement le prix du
sang oui ah on voit ah voilà VO les
images du cercueil donc on VO le
véhicule blindé qui porte encadré par la
Garde Républicaine blind alors ce sont
des images qui ont sont diffusées en ce
moment sur sur le compte Twitter de de
l'Élysée euh donc qui sont également en
direct que rfhaë Lazreg nous met et
qu'on va qu'on va regarder donc ils
viennent de quitter euh les Invalides
qu'on voit encore ouis il vienent de
passer le P le P Alexandre I et ils vont
ils passent devant le Grand Palais en
travaux et ils vont aller s'arrêter donc
dans quelques minutes devant la statue
du général de Gaulle ça c'était une
demande qui a été formulée par Rubert
Germain dans son testament il a demandé
il savait qu'il allait être
enterré sous l'Arc de pardon on voilit
rien et il avait demandé expressément à
ce que lors de du convoi qu'on marque un
temps d'arrêt devant l'institud du
général de
gaaule donc là évidemment le Premier
ministre camala Haris la vice-présidente
des États-Unis et la maire de Paris qui
est compagnon de la Libération aussi
alors la ville de Paris fait partie des
C villes communes de France qui ont été
faites Compagnons de la Libération on
peut les citer donc il y a Grenoble il y
a Nant il y a Paris il y a Vion verc et
il y a l'île de Saint et ce sont parce
que ce sont question de la résistance
j'imagine parce que ce sont des villes
qui ont payé effectivement alors l'île
de sain on peut raconter parce que c'est
c'est une anecdote intéressante c'est
que les marins d' l'île de sain très
jeune tous les hommes quasiment ont pris
leur bateau et ont rejoint l'Angleterre
voilà et d'ailleurs il y a une anecdote
avec le général de Gaulle qui passe en
revue au tout début ça doit être fin
juin ou début juillet 40 qui passe en
revue les volontaires qui viennent
d'arriver et chacun se présente et donne
l'endroit d'où il vient et en fait il
entend évidemment s une centaine de fois
île de sain île de sain et général de GA
dit ainsi la la France est constituée
d'un tiers de l'île de
Saint voilà donc on voit pardon le le le
véhicule qui porte le nom de birakem le
véhicule blindé qui porte la dépouille
du ber
Germain bien escorté voilà et donc le
véhicule s'arrête en face de la statue
du général de Gaulle qu'on voit sur la
droite
effectivement et et la garde qui
s'écarte et qui laisse juste le véhicule
avec la dépoule du
bergermain c'était donc une volonté
Sadio bergermain de s'arrêter de
généralou ABS il a été très très marqué
évidemment il était proche il est resté
proche comme comme beaucoup de
compagnons sont restés proches du
général de Gaulle évidemment
euh et puis il a il le racontait de dans
ses dans ses Mémoires la manière dont il
avait été accueilli parce que au début
général de GA accueillit tous les
volontaire
et je crois j'ai plus les termes exacts
mais le général de GA lui a dit un mot
en lu disant on va avoir besoin de gens
comme vous évidemment ça là à 19 ans
quand vous avez un général qui vient
vous dire ça ouais voilà ça gonfle quand
même le ça vous il disait lui-même ça
vous gonfle quand même le le le
l'orgueil et
cetera le président Macron qui salue la
vice-présidente des
États-Unis
[Musique]
ble
vous allez
bienis l'histoire de sa famille trs à la
France française comme elle a d vous le
dire nous expliquer ça merci d'être
cérémonie magnifique je me sou nous
devions être 15
ans progress va y avoir un discours
particulier à côté là on voit derrière
un podium qui est installé il y a un
discours du président qui est prévu
c'est pour Germain Florence par la
ministre des Armées et
je la ministre secréire
d'État
jeis
pass le même
ch Christian néon toussin qui continue
de de chatter sur le figure.fr je le
remercie je vais je vais relayer son
commentaire c'est éternellement
impressionnant et très prenant le convoi
de reconnaissance qui honore l'homme
soldat aux deux plus hautes décorations
françaises et qui nous su sugère c'est
aussi l'heure d'écouter l'anthologie des
discours de 1940 à 1960 du général de
ble absolument et là le président de la
République salue le chef d'état-major
donc le général murcard qui il faut le
rappeler a été le chef de corps il y a
quelques années de ça quand il était je
crois liutant colonel ou colonel a été
le chef de corps de la 13e d ble donc
pour lui aussi pour pour chef
d'état-major ça a une valeur assez
particulière puisqu'il a commandé
l'unité
euh au sein duquel Hubert Germain a
servi pendant la
guerre
ah et on voit donc le cercueil
arrivé suivi par la garde républicaine
il me semble à
[Musique]
cheval
ça
va
que le président a également un bleu
sur sur son mon un petit peu
obligatoire le ble c'est une œuvre
sociale qui a été créée juste après la
guerre de
14 tout début des années 20
effectivement qui est une association
qui bah tout le monde porte tous Gérard
Larché également et la porte aujourd'hui
aussi et qui aide les familles qui ont
perdu un père
frère un mari un fils à la
[Musique]
guerre
la tour a été démontée non oui c'est il
y a une tourelle avec un canon
effectivement
oui on avait fait la même chose pour le
général de Gaulle
aussi rappelez que lors de l'enterrement
par qu'on a fêté l'anniversaire il y a
de jours l'anniversaire de la mort du
général de Gaulle le 9
novembre lors de son érement puisque
c'est le fondateur de l'ordre de la
Libération et le premier des compagnons
il avait demandé que pour la cérémonie
de son à Colomb les deux églises que
soit qu'elle soit réservée à sa famille
à l'exception des compagnons donc seul
pouvait participer à l'enterrement à
Colombet la famille et les compagnons de
libération il y a une photo qui a
beaucoup circulé sur les réseaux
sociaux ces derniers jours qui a été
publié par un historien qui s'appelle
Eric an très bon historien et qui a publ
une photo de Romain gar qui était
Compagnons de la
Libération ah et donc il était présent
une photo qui a étaéit faite de lui il
était en uniforme il a été dans dans
l'aviation présent à l'enterement et qui
était présent à l'enterrement et on voit
la tête de Gary qui effectivement
d'abord qui a une belle tête et une tête
effectivement chargée
d'émotion à la messe d'enterement du
général de GO la
Colom et voilà le cercueil qui arrive
tout près de l'Arc de
[Musique]
Triomphe le cercueil du Berg donc
dernier compagnon de la libation c'est
un moment quand même hautement
symbolique quoi enfin moi je n'ai pas
souvenir je je je n'ai pas souvenir de
cérémonies comme ça alors euh euh de cet
ordre là enfin il faut que les gens
comprennent quand même qu'on a il y a
une page une grande page de l'histoire
de Guer mondiale qui est en train de se
tourner avec cette cérémonie autour du
Bert Germain c'est quand même très
particulier euh hier moi j'ai été euh
ému enfin je en allant sous le dôme des
Invalides moi j'avais jamais vu ça en
fait hein j'ai pas fait la guerre
évidemment et voilà mais c'est vrai que
on est sur un moment fort historique
historique fort euh voilà et puis le
personnage Dubert Germain en lui-même
était un type aussi au-delà de tout ce
qu'il avait fait il était bah quelqu'un
de positif et de sympathique il a écrit
un livre d'entretien qui était publié il
y a pas très longtemps avec un jeune
auteur aux éditions je crois des belles
lettres ce qui un petit peu son
testament
pour pour les pour le pour les
générations à venir un joli livre
d'entretien
voilà
oser
repos
peut-être qu'on peut raconter l'histoire
du soldat inconnu tout à fait ouais
comment a-t-il été choisi pourquoi voilà
pourquoi le solda inconnu et comment
a-t-il été choisi en fait
euh la guerre de 14 est une guerre c'est
la première grande guerre industrielle
beaucoup de soldats meurent des
suites de l'artillerie des obus des
bombardements et bien souvent il reste
aucun corps donc il y a j'ai plus le
chiffre exact en tête mais son entre 300
et 400000 corps qui n'ont jamais été
retrouvés vous voyez qu'à Verdin euh le
premier jour de l'offensive c'est un
million d'obus qui tomb donc en fait il
y a plus rien euh donc c'est très
difficile de faire le travail de deuil
pour les familles et donc symboliquement
on a eu cette idée euh d'aller euh
choisir euh parmi mis h cercueils ça a
eu lieu en 1920 c'est une initiative je
crois qui été dirigée par André magino
qui a donné son nom à la liine magino
mais qui était un combattant de la
Grande Guerre et donc de d'aller choisir
parmi huit dépouilles de H huit
dépouilles qui viennent de champ de
bataille dont on est sûr que ce sont des
soldats français bien évidemment et on a
confié un jeune combattant de de de la
guerre le soldat Auguste thtin et parmi
les huit cercueils ça a eu lieu à Verdin
Citadel de Verdin il a il a eu le le le
rôle de choisir quel cercue il serait
emmené symboliquement les se autres sont
restés à Verdin ils sont enterrés à
Verdin dans un cimetière militaire et
Auguste tin a l'idée de d'additionner le
chiffre de son régiment il est au 132e
régiment d'infanterie donc il fait 1 3 2
et avec ça il choisit le cercueil qui
est aujourd'hui et qui est qui est là
depuis
1920 qui a été enterré évidemment
symboliquement là et donc encore une
fois c'est pour permettre à ces familles
qui n'ont pas qui n' pas le corps proche
et de de venir faire ce travail de deuil
là
voilà
ouais belles images
ouis une belle
lumière
image est très forte évidemmentbert
Germain repose quelques moments à côté
du du du soldat
inconnu la symbolique aussi symbolique
est très forte bien s bien sûr les de
guerr repos
le président se dirige maintenant pour
prononcer son discours au
pupitre
est-ce qu'il a rare trouver sa
voix petit chat dans la
gorge
française
français serions-nous
là serions-nous là sans Hubert Germain
à 20 ans à peine il quitta tout ces
terres de romoise sa famille ses amis
pour gagner Londres et bientôt avec
honneur et
fidélité se couvrir de gloire à
Birak serions-nous là serions-nous là
sans Philippe Leclerc de Hautecloque
résistant de la première heure
entraînant la deuxè débé dans une épopée
légendaire depuis viire de Libye jusqu'à
la libération de
Paris serions-nous là sans Berty
Albrecht fondatrice avec Hubert ferernet
du réseau de résistance combat tombé aux
mains des allemands et préférant se
donner la mort en prison plutôt que de
risquer de livrer sous la torture ses
camarades de
lutte serions-nous
là serions-nous là sans Philippe kiffer
et 177 fusiliers marins débarquant le 6
juin
1944 sur les plages
normandes serions-nous là sans René
Cassin Jean Moulin Jacques chabandelmas
romain gar et André merau sans ce
cortège de femmes et d'hommes fait de
bravour et de sacrifice pour la
France tous étaient
compagnons ils étaient 1038
illustre et
anonyme
militaire et civil divers par leurs
opinions politiques leurs origines
géographique leur
religion soldats ingénieurs paysans
industriel homme d'église ou homme de
lettrre diplomate ouvriers militantes
Tirailleurs Africains magistrats médecin
ils suivirent le général de Gaulle dans
cette aventure
insensée
tous sans hiérarchie
aucune chevalier de la
liberté
tous sans distinction possible
visage
intemporel de la
France le 16 novembre
1940 il était seul ou
presque convaincu que la France Libre
devait se doter des prérogatives
régaliennes d'un état le général de
Gaulle créa depuis
Brazaville l'Ordre de la
Libération patriam servando
victoriam
toulit le 1er août
1941 ils étaient
c le capitaine de vaisseau Thierry
d'argentlieu le gouverneur général
félixboué le lieutenant d'olonde
l'officier radio télégraphiste de la
marine marchande Popiel et l'adjudant
aviateur bouquillard furent non
seulement les premiers compagnons mais
les premiers membres du Conseil de
l'Ordre
pionnier venu de toute la
France issu de toutes les
conditions le 11 novembre
1945 ils étaient 15
ici 15 cercueils drapés de tricolore
remontant les Champs Élysées qui venus
de tous les champs de bataille se
placèrent en arc à l'heure du triomphe
flambeau de la résistance mêlé à la
flamme du soldat inconnu avant de
rejoindre la crypte du montvérien pour
témoigner devant l'histoire que durant
cette guerre ses fils ont lutté pour que
la France vive
libre 15 dépouille de tirailleurs
tunisiens marocains sénégalais de
résistant de soldats de 39 40 de
Français libres de la Résistance
intérieure comme de l'armée de la
Libération burkinabé tchadien breton
résistant déporté tous ici
rassemblés le 9 mars
1952 une 16e dépouille les rejoignait
dans la
crypte celle d'un soldat
français fusillé en adochine
dépouilles pour représenter tous les
destins de l'ordre des
compagnons
l'ordre sur décision de son grand maître
était fort clos en
1946 et ne fut exceptionnellement
ouvert que pour accueillir Winston
Churchill et Sa Majesté George VI
chacun savait dès
lors que le jour
viendrait où il faudrait dire adieu au
dernier
compagnons celui qui prendrait dans la
crypte la dernière
place ce jour est
venu conformément à la volonté exprimée
par le général de Gaulle Hubert Germain
rejoindra cet après-midi au
montvalérien ces frères de combat et
avec eux tous ceux qui se sont levés
pour que vive la
France les compagnons
alors ne seront
plus les 18 unités combattantes
continueront d'arborer l'emblème des
compagnons ragère noire pour le deuil
verte pour
l'espoir la croix de laorine ornera
encore les blasons des communes
compagnons Nantes Grenoble Paris Vion
vercor l'île de
Saint l'ordre
surtout
vivra protégé par le chef de l'État
gardien de la mémoire de ces femmes et
de ces hommes qui un jour se sont hissés
au-delà de même pour la liberté de tous
il fera des compagnons de la liberté une
source éternelle d'inspiration pour tous
les enfants de
France toujours
uni certaines
nations sont faites de frontières
partagées d'hérédit de
sang la France s'est construite sur ces
terres par une histoire une langue un
état par une
volonté la France vit
survit surmonte les épreuves des temps
grâce à des femmes et des hommes qui
unit par un amour pour sa terre ses
idéaux et ses valeurs accepte de risquer
jusqu'à leur vie pour une cause plus
grande
queux la France est
liberté la France est transmission
elle
vit survit et surmondte ses épreuves
parce que de génération en génération
des femmes et des hommes se transmettent
le flambeau de l'idéal
alors
oui le dernier compagnon n'est
plus et nous l'accompagnerons jusque
dans cette crypte où nous sellerlerons
le dernier
caveau mais ces 10 38 qui ont épousé la
France d'un amour inconditionnel allant
jusqu'au sacrifice ne disparaissent pas
pour autant ils rejoignent nos morts et
de bouvine au chemins des dames de paté
à valmi de reince à coufra ils
inscrivent leur destin au côté de ceux
qui ont porté l'esprit de résistance
l'amour d'une patrie libre le refus des
divisions pour l'honneur de la France
alors
oui oui leurs braises ardentes sont dans
nos
mains et quand viendra le
jour quand sonnera l'heure
nous saurons les
raviver de ce souffle qui fit lever tous
ceux qui nous précèdent et qui nous ont
fait
[Musique]
libre
français et sans lesquels nous ne
serions pas
là vive la
République vive la France
[Musique]
emblème rejoignez vos
gardes
repos Gard
vous cessz le
[Musique]
feu
dans dans le chat je vais je vais lire
quelques commentaires de des internautes
qui suivent avec nous donc ces
commémorations du 11 novembre et ce
dernier hommage rendu à Hubert Germain
benénedict Gaspard sur Youtube qui dit
vive mon grand-père victorieux à Verdin
vive la France Jean NG guyen en mémoire
de tous ces héros on n'oublie pas et on
avance vers la lumière pour les
générations futures et Christiane osen
ne les oublions
pas
on commémore l'armistice mais aussi tous
les soldats morts c'est aussi le jour de
commémoration de tous les soldats morts
pour la France oui avec le 8 8 45 mais
oui bien sûr et tous les jours on r vive
la flamme je sais plus si on l'a dit
tout à l'heure tous les jours je CIS que
c à 18h une association patronique
depuis que le le soldat inconnu est
enterré donc sous l'Arc de Triomphe en
1920 tous les jours à 18h une
association d'anciens combattants donc
de toutes les guerres qui ont suivi
vient raviver cette flamme qui sert
également et on le verra tout à l'heure
à raviver la flamme qui brûle elle aussi
au mémorial du Mont Valérien donc c'est
le lien entre les deux guerres
euh voilà
sonnerie au
[Musique]
mort
allons enfant de la
patrie le jour de gloire est
arrivé contreous de la
tiranie
assemblant
élev les assemant élev
en les
campagnes
il f
compagnesous bataillons Mar marchons
marchons marchons
marchons
impulion reposer
repos Grégoire ton maintenant qu'on
enterre le dernier compagnon de la
Libération
quel avenir on peut envisager pour cet
ordre maintenant qu'il est fort cl bah
c'est la difficulté effectivement c'est
qu' qu'on que l'ordre continue à
maintenir ce ce travail de de mémoire de
mémoire de partage des valeurs qui ont
fait qui ont fait les compagnons voilà
donc c'est finalement il y a un enjeu
pour eux hein c'est que c'est qu'il
continuent à arriver à porter ce message
peut-être pour ça qu' bah il continue à
faire un certain nombre d'action il faut
vraiment aller visiter le musée de
l'ordre parce que
c'est euh c'est un musée qui est très
émouvant pour plein de raisons parce que
vous avez des objets évidemment qui qui
sont liés à à des des des des moments
d'histoire je pense à un en particulier
mais il y en a plein d'autres c'est que
vous avez un pistolet d'ordonnance un
peu stulé qui avait des officiers
pendant la guerre de 14 qui avait un un
un officier qui était un des proches du
Général Leclerc et en en en en août 44
quand il est quand Leclerc arrive on a
parlé de 2è dB le président de la
République on a parlé tout à l'heure
évidemment général le est compagnon et
beaucoup des gens qui étaient avec
Lecler son compagnon euh euh pendant la
bataille de Normandie où où Leclerc
effectivement débarque en août 44 au
détour d'un d'un d'un chemin il se
retrouve avec une patrouille allemande
et en fait c'est génér le capitaine je
crois de guilbon à l'époque et Lecler
avançait beaucoup toujours et cetera et
à ce moment-là gubon sort son réolur il
a que ça sur lui et il descend les deux
Allemands et dit mais sinon ce jour-là
peut- peut-êre lecl c'était lui ou nous
enfin c'était eux ou nous et voilà et
vous avez ce pistolet en fait qui qui a
peut-être changé le cours dehoire on le
sait pas évidemment mais qui alors
Leclerc meurt dans des conditions tout
aussi dramatiques son avion s'écrase 2
ans après la guerre on sait pas quelle
carrière il aa eu d'ailleurs après mais
mais voilà vous avez plein d'objets
comme ça qui sont très qui sont chargés
d'histoire vous avez un ours en plus qui
a été offert en général Kenig par les
Britanniques après après birakem et elle
a laamène parce qu'en fait Kenig en
allemand ça veut dire lion et en fait il
lui offre un ours en plus qu' a qu' a
gardé enfin c'est c'est évidemment vous
a mis un offici qui est de légion
général qui vient de combattre dans le
désert on lui offre un our plus mais je
trouve que c'est il y a plein de
témoignages comme ça vous avez des
cordes qui ont été utilisé par des des
résistants pour s'échapper de prison et
cetera je voilà faut vraiment aller voir
ce musée qui est 13S à l'échelle humaine
qui a été refait il y a pas longtemps
donc est vraiment au niveau de tout ce
qui est muséographique très très moderne
et très bien fait voilà et il est basé
invalide à
Paris
reposer
repos
Marinette sur Youtube qui qui qui fait
part de son commentaire très bel hommage
n'oublions pas c'est
héros c'était un héros donc Hubert
Germain ou évidemment ou bien sûr il a
été m de fois décoré récompensé pour ces
actes de bravour bien
évidemment le chef d'étatmajor de
l'armée de
terre j'ai oublié son nom
vous avez tous les chefs d'état-major
donc terre her mer le chef d'étatmajor
de l'armée on a parlé tout à
l'heure à côté du président du Sénat
est-ce qu'on peut parler du rôle des
Américains donc dans la oui on peut
parler du rôle des américains pendant la
Grande Guerre donc évidemment il nentr
en guerre qu'en
1917 voilà donc évidemment ils vont
parti
à l'effort de guerre et à la victoire
même si techniquement et
opérationnellement l'armée américaine
n'existait quasiment pas avant la guerre
puisque une armée en gros c'est entre
guillemets de garde frontière et c'est
la guerre de 14 qui va faire que elle se
développe il y a un million de personnes
un million de soldats qui qui débarquent
en France mais qui sont formés par des
officiers sous-officiers français parce
qu'en fait ils sont ils ont pas
d'expérience de de combat alors que les
Français long et viennent de faire 3 ans
de guerre avec les pertes qu'on connaît
euh voilà donc qui participe et
médiatiquement effectivement
psychologiquement le fait de savoir que
l'Amérique entre en guerre avec déjà sa
puissance industrielle ça a une
incidence évidemment sur le moral des
Allemands euh des Autrichiens des Turcs
euh voilà donc ça c'est le patron de la
gendarmerie me
semble-t-il je crois vu aussi le patron
de la
DGSE après juste après qui lui n'est pas
entenu je ne sais pas qui
c'est peut-être si on pour parler de la
guerre de
14 redonner quand même quelques chiffres
et les mettre un peu en perspective donc
la guerre de 14 c'est pour nous Français
he c'est environ 1400000 morts voilà ce
qui veut dire ce qui veut rien dire
parce que c'est très compliqué de
s'imagineer ce que ça représente 1
400000 morts si on fait une moyenne par
jour de guerre c'est 800 80 soldats qui
tombent chaque jour en moyenne bien sûr
il y a des jours où c'est beaucoup plus
bien sûr bien Jû la bataille de Verdin
c'est beaucoup plus la bataille de la
Somme qui en fait la bataille la plus
meurtrière voilà ça c'est le patron de
la je crois de la DGSE me
semble-t-il est-ce qu'on sait combien
d'Allemands sont morts au combat la
grand oui oui oui tout à fait il y a un
peu plus que les Français parce que
il étit un peu plus nombreux
effectivement il y a 1900000 morts au
total la grande
guerre c'est environ 9 millions de morts
hein voilà les Américains j'avais mis
ils ont perdu 100000 hommes un peu plus
de 100000 hommes voilà quand tu français
on perde 1400000 bon enfin ça se passe
sur notre
territoire ils sont arrivés à la fin
bien sûr donc donc
voilà mais la GU 14 c'est 300000 mutilés
un million
d'invalides 600000 veuves de guerre on
voit effectivement tout le monde porte
le le Bleu de France qui qui l'œuvre
sociale qui vient aider les les familles
qui ont perdu des des proches à la
guerre 700000 orphelins 400000 immeubles
détruits ou usines 3 million d'hectares
de terres agricoes qui sont déclaré
impropres à toute exploitation quand
vous allez à Verdin aujourd'hui à cause
des restes d'obus bien sûr d'une part et
puis aussi et sur certains champs de
bataille Verdin c'est vraiment ça c'est
que en fait vous retrouvez encore
régulièrement des des osmans euh voilà
donc le le lieu est sanctuarisé pour des
raison de sécurité et parce que en fait
c'est on considère que c'est une
sépulture euh de fait euh
voilà alors les Américains puisqu'on a
vu qu'il y avait la vice-présidente qui
était là les américains ils sont très
impressionnés par les le cérémonial
militaire en France Trump quand il était
venu au au début de de son mandat Macron
l'avait invité au défilé du 14 juillet
il était revenu aux états-unisant je
veux la même chose bon il avait assisté
à un défilé
militaire je ne sais pas qui est cette
dame que celle du président de la
République il est fort probable que ce
une proche du bergermain peut-être je
sais pas si c'est une proche du
bergermain ou si c'est une femme qui
est peut-être médailler de la résistance
par que vous savez que lors de la
Libération il y a deux ordres vous avez
les compagnons donc le dernier donc
aujourd'hui et les médaillés qui étaient
eux pour le coup pas 1038 mais environ
70000 et il restent encore des
résistants j'ai entendu dire dans
certains médias que le dernier des
résistants était morts avec huberjamin
non il y a encore des résistants et Dieu
merci qui sont vivants évidment ils sont
très âgés euh donc vous pouvez être
résistant sans avoir été Compagnons de
la Libération les compagnons encore une
fois c'est un ordre chevalier c'est
particulier hein c'est les premiers des
premiers à s'engager mais il y a
d'autres résistants qui s'engagent au
cours de la guerre et de manière tout à
fait honorable qui combattent et qui
sont encore vivants et qui peuvent avoir
été médaillés aussi de la résistance
donc est le deuxème qui a créé le
général de Gaulle peu peu peu de temps
après effectivement pour récompenser
d'autres actes effectivement de de bah
de résistance voilà
bonjour les drapeau mais je sais pas on
voit pas
lesations je les vois comment
allez-vous
je retrouve tous Merci à VOUS hein vous
êtes en forme ça va oui merci à vous
tout à l'heure à tout à l'heure
présidentational
parist bag Je je reconnais tous les
visagesion étrangè j'ai fait référence
vert donc laéion étrangère compris je
parlaismain
j'ai
merci régiment 5
régiment merci à tout de
suite
com je sais bien que le Président de la
République prenne le temps d'aller
saluer tous les portes drapeau des
associations d'anciens combattants
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs on voit un drapeau
américain au
fond d'entre vous personne qui dem je ne
souviens pas le nom de la chanson que le
cœur a chanté il y avait la marciè et le
champ des partisans ou c'est le champ
des partisans oui il y en avait pas
d'autres je pense que c'était ça bah le
champ des partisans oui parce que ça
s'impose évidemment c'est le champ de la
résistance qui a été écrit par Joseph
Kessel et Maurice
Druon mis en musique par Anna Marle
effectivement qui a été repris pu qui
est le champ qui symbolise la résistance
française pendant pendant la guerre donc
c'était bien normal que ce chant très
joli soit chanté
cérémonie
comment ça
va
it
d'habitud merci bonne continuation
comment ça va monsieur le Président du
fond du monond cur je qu' des bonnes
choses pour vous et pour le peuple
français vivre notre alliance
franco-grecque et vive la France ou
merci
beaucouput pas oublier
les monsie
président
chci
toujours
là fétion DESS
et je P que
vousz poussant la barbe parce que les
conditions de vie sont difficiles
éidment les conditions de vie son ile
dans les tranchées pendant pendant la
guerre de 141 mais en fait le poilu
c'est un terme d'argot qui date de bien
avant la guerre un poilu c'est c'est un
homme qui a du poil au bon endroit en
gros comprendre un homme courageux un
courageux uniril un fier mais surtout un
courageux donc c'est pas quelqu'un qui
se qui se laisse aller c'est pas ça et
d'ailleurs dans les tranchées de la
guerre de 14-18 si les hommes parce que
c'est la mode de l'époque beaucoup
d'hommes porte la moustache on ne porte
pas la barbe à et notamment à partir de
1915 pour une raison très simple et qui
est juste une question de vie ou de mort
c'est que vous AZ les premières attaques
au gaz donc on se protège au début comme
on peut les premiers masques à gaz sont
pas formidables et donc évidemment il
est peu recommandé de se laisser pousser
la barbe parce que évidemment ça laisse
passer les gaz donc je peux vous dire
que dans les tranchées même si bien
évidemment il y a pas l' courante on se
rase et les hommes se rasent se rasent
entre eux mais ils se rasent donc on
peut porter la barbe encore une fois
voilà et donc un poilu c'est un homme
courageux et pour et tout ça vient alors
c'est c'est c'est de l'argot c'est de
l'argot c'est de l'argot re poilu c'est
être courageux c'est un courageux un po
c'est un courageux voilà et pour parler
d'un autre terme de la guerre du 14 pu
c'est c'est un vocabulaire du de 14 18
les bosches Bosch en fait ça vient de
cabochche tête dure h voilà et et et et
en fait à l'origine ça date même je
crois de la guerre de 70 on parlait des
Allemands en en en en en en en en en
associant le mot allemand avec tête dure
qui faisait alboche un alboche c'est un
Allemand à tête dure et c'est devenu par
contraction un Bosche voilà ah oui alors
qu'on aurait pu penser que c'était un
mot allemand en fait Bos Bosche caboche
non ça vient de l'Argo
français et les Allemands utilisaient un
mot qui veut dire quasiment la même
chose en parlant du soldat français je
crois alors je je je parle pas allemand
je crois que c'est calmuser et qui veut
dire aussi tête dure parce que pour les
Allemands le soldat français il avait la
tête dure c'est qu'il était résistant
quoi
[Musique]
commentzés
merci Guer de
des
mon c'est 1500 donc 141 c'est 1562 jours
de guerre soit 4 ans 3 mois et 12 jours
3 août 14 11 novembre 19
disit tout à l'heure avec une moyenne n
qu'une moyenne mais de 880 soldats qui
tombent chaque jour
français donc c'est la pire
saignée connu la France parce que la
guerre de 39 45 aussi horrible et qui
fait bien plus de morts nous il y a eu
des combats en ma juin 40 y a à peu près
environ on 100000
mors pendant les combat de 40 et puis
après il y a d'autres morts
évidemment par la suite mais ça n' rien
àir avec les pertes qu' connu l'armée
française et la France pendant la guerre
du
141 je ve un dans le et on peut
comprendre ça au nom de nombre de morts
c'est qu'en France il y a je crois 36000
communes peu près envir 36000 communes
vous avez 30000 environ 30000 monuments
morts donc quasiment toutes les communes
oua enfin tout le monde a se souvient du
monument mort du petit village a pu
vivre passer ses vacances ou euh
voilà comment
allez-vous je
sou des Russes là vous venez oui oui je
dire ça marche parce que l'armée russe a
envoyé des volontaires qui ont combattu
jusqu'à lament 17 il avait la révolution
mais qui ont combattu au côté des
Français qui avait un corps de
volontaire russe chasseur à pied alors
ils sont batttu évidemment eux sur avec
les Allemands de leur côté
maisén et le général Darry que je suis
DEP généralry
bienve avec je
saisêern je sais
bien comment allez-vous ben écoutez ça
va très bien je suis très heureuse c'est
une sériémonie vraiment exceptionnelle
elle est très belle et votre discours
aussi et d'autant plus que je suis là
tous les
soirs la à la cérémie parce que je veux
pas que cette petite flamme s'éte le
jour elle va s'éind ben voilà il faut
savoir
laité merci
beaucoup je
suisirpace vous allez bien très bien
monsieur merci d'être là une me fis
encore comment allez-v Monsieur le
Président très heure evir je ministre de
l'Intérieur j'imerais vous dire quand
même que je suis aussi professeuration
civiquetion et
doncalement transport de la flamme
parverdin lame sacré qui a lie il y 15
jours donc j'aianis
ministèreériur
merciit merci
Madame qu'il a fallu 2009 pour que pour
cette cérémonie pour la première fois
que un représentant de l'État allemand
en l'occurence c'est Angela Merkel qui
participe la première fois c'est en 2009
c'est la première fois que la France l'
invité ou la première fois que les
Allemands acceptent de venir comment ça
se passe une bonne question c'est une je
ne sais pas je pas dire de bêtis je ne
sais pas mais c'est la première fois
qu'un chancelier allemand participe
bon il y a eu cette poignée de main
symbolique qui a été faite par mitteran
ELM tout à fait à Verdin je crois que
c'est en
1984 pour l'anniversaire aussi Dubut de
la guerre donc il a eu cette qui était
spontané para-il mais je ne sais pas
mais
voilà mais après ils sont pas
systématiquement invités non mais le
fait pour la première fois un chancelier
allemand
participe des
combattants
deis j'ai la chance d'être
invité en 2018 pour la fin du centenaire
à cette cérémonieétais dans les tribunes
et il y a eu un beau moment et qui a
repris ce qui historiquement s'est passé
lorsque l'armistice a été signé donc le
11 novembre 1918 à 11h 11
euh toute à l'époque les cloches se sont
mises à sonner parce qu'à l'époque c'est
un moyen de communication les cloches on
a sonné le toxin quand il a fallu faire
l'appel et la mobilisation générale mais
on a aussi sonné le toxin pour annoncer
la fin de la guerre et le 11 novembre
2018 moi j'étais là sur la sur la Place
de l'Étoile dans le
public et on a entendu les cloches de
Paris qui ont raésonné à
11h11 symboliquement appel c ça c'est le
général Puga qui est le patron de la
Légion d'honneur qui est le premier
ordre en
France on rappelle que l'ARM su n'a pas
été signé à Paris hein li non il a été
signé dans la clairrière de Roton en
Picardie voilà c'est la Picardie c'est
le oui c'est dans c'est dans l'Oise non
à
côéou tout à fait ouou voilà le général
Baptiste qui est le général qui dirige
aujourd'hui l'ordre des compagnons de
libération on vient de voir à
l'écran donc chargé de faire perdurers
la mémoire de de cet ord compagonstion
et des valeurs
merci à
vous c'est un élu mais je ne sais pas je
ne sais pas d'où mais avec son écharpe
d'élu c'est peut-être les maires des
communes des compagnons puis qu'il
aidalgo dans le lot ou c'est peut-être
ça bien sûr ce sont les maires des CIN
communes donc Grenoble Nantes Paris euh
vassion vercor et l'île de Saint
évidemment vous avez raison c'est ça
alors du coup qui est qui par contre ça
je peux pas vous dire ah les noms je
connais pas bah enfinalgon la connaît
oui ah ça c'est le maire de grenhomme je
crois oui Eric Piol il est connu aussi
le
fameux formidable qui n'a pas mis son
écharpe qui n'a pas mis de cravate non
plus pour une cérémonie officielle mais
enfin bon
voilà faut qu'il marque son son camp
voilà c'est ça
Christian Léon toussin dans le chat
grande émotion merci pour ce direct et
bon bon 11 novembre à
nous
la
T
gouvernementou du
gouvernement donc la MA de
Paris ça je ne sais pas une autre des
communes du coup autre le maire d'une
autre des communes compagnon de la
Libération
[Musique]
ésident
du travail au
de
Nantes également bien s il y a pas la
mère de Nant parce que c'est une
femme alors peut-être que son là ce sont
les je ne sais pas c'est je sais pas qui
sont ces officiers chef de corps
peut-être des unités des 18 unités
compagnons donc on va le voir s'ils sont
18 sont 18 on
comprendra je sais
pas Marinette saudr legr qui nous
demande si les jeunes générations ne
sont pas invité ou mêlé au commémoration
c'est vrai qu'on n pas vu beaucoup
peut-être dans le public dans les
tribunes si il y en a bien sûr si si
bien sûr et puis je pense que cet
après-midi au monv rien alors la
cérémonie je sais pas quelle est
l'ampleur de la cérémonie mais il y a
toujours des enfants au monv les rien
parce que la cérémonie du montven c'est
le 18 juin évidemment il y a toujours
des classes qui sont présentes euh voilà
moi il m'arrive de faire sur certains
livres peut-être qu'on le fera sur les
compagnons vous avez ce qu'on appelle
les classes défens qui sont un peu plus
impliqués effectivement sur tout ce qui
est univers militaire devoir de mémoire
et cetera voilà et puis les associations
patriotiques souvent mène aussi avec eux
des des élèves des jeunes
voilà
la bataille le cercueil voilà qui le
cercueil qui s'envoie sur le véhicule
qui porte le nom de birakem pour
reparler de la bataille de birakem en
fait puisque ça marque un tournant en
fait pour nous et pour les Français
Libres la bataille de birakem elle
marque le retour dans la guerre de la
France après la défaite l'arrêt des
hostilités c'est la première fois et
c'est la bataille de birakem donc en
fait c'est pas en soit une victoire
c'estàd qu'on stoppe l'avancée des
troupes italo-allemandes dirigé par
Romel qui veut se diriger vers l'Égypte
et contrôler le canal évidemment le
canal de Suède et donc la 13e des ble
dont fait partie Hubert Germain au sein
de la première division française le
puisqu'il y a d'autres unités tient ce
verrou là et freine l'avancée allemande
et permet aux troupes anglaises de se
réorganiser et c'est un tournant de la
guerre et et donc donc cette cette
bataille qui dure une quinzaine presque
une quinzaine de jours
elle a un retentissement médiatique
international et et effectivement et le
général de Gaul à ce moment-là
communique et fait un il faut que je le
retrouve parce que je l'ai pas je
connais pas de mémoire mais il a il a
une citation tout à fait
particulière qui parle de ça je vais pas
le retrouver euh et donc à ce moment-là
effectivement donc symboliquement mais
enfin médiatiquement on dit pas le terme
à l'époque mais mais
effectivement la France repart repart au
combat et avec donc la première division
français libre au sein duquel on a
notamment la 13e d ble au sein duquel
sert Hubert Germain voilà dont on voit
le véhicule qui porte le nom de cette
bataille qui fait le tour de l'Arc de
Triomphe voilà j'imagine sans doute je
pas le détail du protocole mais que sont
représentés tout autour de l'arc des des
soldats de ces 18 unités il a forcément
la 3è d ble et puis les autres
évidemment il y a donc des tribunes avec
le public où sont peut-être installés
justement les élèves les écoles les
jeunes générations dont on parlait tout
à
l'heure voilà donc le convoi qui va se
diriger vers nanter au montvalérien pour
l'inumation dans dans la crypte du
bergermain donc qui aa lieu en début
d'après-midi je je crois vers 1430 de
14h30 à 15h il me
[Musique]
semble ah voilà j'ai retrouvé la j'ai
retrouvé la sitituation du général de
Gaulle parlant de la bataille de birakem
qui disait la nation a tressailli de
fierté en apprenant ce qu'on fait ses
soldats à birakem brave et pur enfants
de France qui viennent d'écrire avec
leur sang une de ses plus belles page de
gloire donc le général de GA dans un
discours à la BBC le 11 juin
1942 Emmanuel Macron avait rencontré à
plusieurs repris
avec des entretiens avec Hubert
Germain voir plusieurs
fois qui se dirige vers la défense voilà
vers le 92
donc
repos
le général de saintchama qui dirige
l'Institut des Invalides qui
accueille qui qui est à la fois une
maison de retraite et un hôpital et qui
accueille bah nombre d'anciens
combattants d'invalides voilà donc
Hubert Germain a passer les derniers
mois de sa vie au sein de l'Institut des
Invalides et donc là ce sont des anciens
combattants ce sont des anciens
combattants pensionnaires aussi des voir
je crois qu'il une croix de guerre 39
45 encore quelques combattants de 39 45
évidemment les rangs
s'éclaircissent
ini pour Institut National des Invalides
envoie les couvertur qu'ils
[Musique]
ont
alors vous avez un combattant illustre
aussi qui était avec le le commandant
kiffer puisque le président de la
République a parlé tout à l'heure du
commandant kiffer qui a débarqué le 6
juin 44 avec les commandos
marines les 1677 hommes du commando
kiffer et il reste un survivant qui
s'appelle léon Gautier qui a 99 ans que
j'ai rencontré aussi encore il vit
encore en Normandie euh au dernière
nouvelle il allit plutôt pas trop mal il
vient de fêter son anniversaire c'est 99
ans et lui a participé alors il est pas
compagnon desotier mais enfin il a do
avoir quelques décoration quand même le
le commandant kiffer lui était fait
compagnonilà il a débarqué le 6 juin 44
sur les plages normandes il fait partie
des 177 français qui ont pris pied sur
le sol français ce
[Musique]
jourl
on entend la musique la Garde
[Musique]
Républicaine
changé de
champ images alors ou c'est pas raccord
dans la réalisation je P petit
décalage
ah ancien président de la République et
le président de l'Assemblée nationale
tout à
fait j'ai pas s'il y avait Nicolas
[Musique]
Sarkozy
les membres du
[Musique]
gouvern
la cérémonie la cérémonie touche à sa
fin
et donc en début d'après-midi on
retrouvera le président de la République
oui c'est ça l'issu de de cette
cérémonie donc le le le convoi euh le le
char avec le le cercueil du benjamin se
se dirige vers le le 92 les haut de
scèes pour le le Mont Valérien pour un
ultime hommage donc c'est c'est à partir
de
14h30 de nouveau en présence du chef de
l'État d'Emmanuel Macron mais cette
fois-ci la cérémonie elle sera plus
intime ouais voilà plus sobre et en
silence il y aura pas de discours du du
président il y aura simplement donc une
Marseillaise et et une nouvelle fois le
le champ des partisans selon les
informations de de l'Élysée et puis
ensuite Emmanuel Macron se recueillera
seul dans la
crypte juste devant le le cercueil sur
lequel il déposera une croix de Lorine
taillée dans le bois de la charpente de
la cathédrale Notre-Dame de Paris comme
l'avait souhaité Hubert Germain ah voilà
c'est sont des infos qui sont très Croy
effectivement bergermain euh tout à fait
ah oui je je je l'apprends ça ouais
ouais ah c'est bien comme symbole
ça donc il y aura pas de caméra dans la
crypte he il entre seul bien sûr le
président de la
[Musique]
République
voilà vous venez de de suivre en direct
avec nous pendant plus de plus d'unehure
et demi hein 1h45
même donc ces commémorations de de
l'armistice du 11 novembre et surtout ce
der dernier hommage de la nation rendu à
ubert Germain donc dernier compagnon de
de la Libération qui s'est éteint en
octobre à l'âge de 101 ans merci à
Grégoire tona merci à vous d'avoir été
avec nous encore une fois pour commenter
ce direct je rappelle à tous ceux qui
nous regardent que vous êtes auteur du
des enfin auteur des petits quiz qui
apparaîent à l'écran et que j'ai aussi
avec moi donc sur la 13e d ble sur les
Compagnons de la Libération mais aussi
sur la grande guerre mais sur sur plein
d'autres thèmes historiques donc ce sont
des petits pe quiz à retrouver aux
éditions pierre de Tayac je remercie
également Raphaël Lazreg à la
réalisation de ce direct et je remercie
tous les internautes qui ont commenté
dans le chat et qui nous ont suivi sur
notre page Youtube Figaro live mais
aussi sur le Figaro.fr j'en salue
quelques-uns Sonia de souousa du Bonard
Benedict Gaspard Marinette sauderet ler
et puis sur Le Figaro.fr la faute à
Voltaire et Christian léont toussin deux
fidèles internautes de Figaro live euh
je vous rappelle que vous vous pouvez
suivre donc sur Figaro live à 14h30
l'inumation au mot Valérien du du
dernier compagnon de la Libération
Hubert Germain et quant à moi je vous
retrouve bientôt sur un pour un prochain
direct merci à vous de nous avoir suivi
et bon 11
novembre